-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is ''Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden on Saturday
visited Los Angeles,
where his motorcade reportedly
caused traffic delays.
Oh, come on,
it's Los Angeles.
That's like saying
he visited New York
and caused subway delays.
No, he didn't. Just happens.
[ Laughter ]
During the National
Prayer Breakfast last week,
President Biden and
House Speaker Mike Johnson
appeared to cry during singer
Andrea Bocelli's rendition
of "Amazing Grace" -- Biden
because he was moved
by the performance,
and Johnson because Andrea
is a girl's name.
[ Laughter ]
At a rally yesterday in Nevada,
President Biden criticized
former President Trump's
economic record
and called him, quote,
Donald "Herbert Hoover" Trump,
a comment that has
Trump supporters
frantically Googling
"Herbert Hoover."
And Biden supporters.
Come on, who are we kidding?
I don't know
what that means either.
During an interview yesterday,
former President Trump
discussed his criteria
for selecting a vice president
and said, "It's got to be
who is going to be
a good president.
You always have
to think about that."
Yeah, we know, dude.
I love it when he's
the last person on earth
to figure something out,
and then he wants
to explain it to us.
It's like having
a kid in school.
"Dad, did you know there are
three kinds of rocks?"
"Yeah, everybody knows that."
"Well, then name 'em, Dad."
"I don't know the names!
I just know
there are three kinds!
And I know nothing about
Herbert Hoover, so don't ask!"
After several right-wing
media personalities
began to claim recently
that Taylor Swift
is part of a Pentagon
operation to influence
the presidential election,
a Defense Department
spokesperson said,
"We know all too well the
dangers of conspiracy theories.
So, to set the record straight,
Taylor Swift is not
part of a DoD psychological
operation, period."
Because if there's one thing
that will sway
conspiracy theorists,
it's an official statement
from the Pentagon.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Adams last week
announced a new strategy
for the city's sanitation system
that will store trash bags,
instead of piling them up
on the street to be picked up.
It's part of his plan
to bring New York City
all the way in to the 1990s.
[ Laughter ]
Adams also announced
the finalized rules
for outdoor dining
and said, "We're
fundamentally transforming
what it feels like
to be outside New York."
Good, because no one here
can afford to be inside.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida man was arrested
recently
after he allegedly entered
a church thrift store naked --
naked -- and stole a T-shirt.
He's being charged
with also not stealing pants.
[ Laughter ]
In honor of Valentine's Day,
Popeyes is offering
limited-edition heart-shaped
strawberry biscuits
with a drizzle of icing,
after which your heart
will no longer be heart-shaped.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, crew members
of a floating sauna in Oslo
recently rescued two passengers
from a car
that accidentally
drove into a fjord.
For more stories like this,
pick up a copy
of "Mad Libs:
Norwegian Edition."
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.
[ Cheers and applause ]